digamos que nos dan la ecuación cuadrada
menos equis cuadrada es igual a 4 y
queremos encontrar la segunda derivada
de con respecto a x queremos encontrar
una expresión en términos de x y de jess
para esta causa en el vídeo y traten de
resolver esto por su cuenta vamos a
resolverlo juntos quizá alguno de
ustedes se le ocurre despejar la aie y
usar algunas técnicas tradicionales pero
aquí tenemos la guía al cuadrado lo que
implica tener más menos la raíz cuadrada
de algo por lo que quizás se les ocurra
que podemos hacer algo de derivación
implícita que es una aplicación de la
regla de la cadena vamos a hacer lo
primero encontremos la primera derivada
de con respecto a x para hacer esto
calculamos la derivada con respecto a x
en ambos lados de la ecuación para
encontrar la derivada de cuadrada con
respecto a x usamos la regla de la
cadena
primero calculamos la derivada de
cuadrada con respecto a y que es igual a
12 que después multiplicamos con la
derivada de y con respecto a x a esto le
vamos a restar la derivada de x cuadrada
con respecto a x que es 2x y sólo nos
falta calcular la derivada de una
constante con respecto a x que es igual
a 0 ahora vamos a despejar la primera
derivada de ye con respecto a x sumamos
2 en ambos lados y nos quedan 2 por la
derivada de con respecto a x es igual a
2 x ahora dividimos ambos lados entre 12
lo que nos da que la derivada de con
respecto a x es igual a x entre y el
siguiente paso es calcular la derivada
de todo esto con respecto a x y así
esperamos encontrar la segunda derivada
de jake con respecto a x para hacerlo
vamos a reescribir esto y bueno a mí
siempre se me olvida la regla del
cociente pero a ustedes les puede ser
útil recordarla pero podemos reescribir
esto como un producto lo cual nos va a
ayudar a encontrar lo que queremos la
derivada de y con respecto a x es igual
a x porque a la potencia menos 1 ahora
aplicamos el operador derivada a ambos
lados de la ecuación para encontrar la
segunda derivada con respecto a x en el
lado izquierdo tenemos lo que queda
encontrar la segunda derivada de con
respecto a x y del lado derecho que
vamos a tener aplicamos la regla del
producto primero tenemos la derivada de
x con respecto a x que es igual a 1 x a
la potencia menos 1 a esto le sumamos x
x la derivada del ala menos 1 cuál es la
derivada de a la menos uno primero
encontramos la derivada de iu a la menos
uno con respecto a y que es aplicar la
regla de la cadena nos queda menos 1
porque a la menos 2 y multiplicamos esto
por la derivada de ye con respecto a x
recuerden que ya sabemos a que es igual
la derivada de ye con respecto a x es
esto de aquí x entre y lo sustituimos
acá finalmente tenemos que simplificar
esta expresión
vamos a hacerlo por partes esto es igual
a 1 entre y en esta otra parte vemos que
el signo negativo va primero tenemos x
por esta x en el numerador que será
dividida entre una cuadrada multiplicada
por otra y esto nos queda menos x
cuadrada entre y al cubo
o también podríamos verlo como x
cuadrada por al menos 3 con esto hemos
encontrado lo que buscábamos la segunda
derivada de g con respecto a x en
términos de x 10 nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo